on the first day of Obamacare's
enrollment Secretary of Health and Human
Services Kathleen Sebelius has
preemptively begged forgiveness for
technical difficulties by comparing the
launch of health care reform to the
release of a new Apple product hopefully
she explained Americans will give us the
same site they give Apple if there's not
quite the operational excellence right
away we'll continue to press for them
but here are three reasons why Obamacare
eat no iPhone using Apple products is
strictly voluntary unlike Obamacare
nobody is forced to pick up the latest
iPhone or mat and thank God nobody is
forced to use inferior offerings such as
Apple maps Apple like other once mighty
tech giants such as Nokia and rim is
only a string of bad releases away from
going belly-up the federal government
not so much even on its busiest days you
can usually get into an apple store and
you can always get online at apple com
compare that to the experience of early
birds trying to access the health
insurance exchanges at healthcare.gov or
residents of whole states like Colorado
and Oregon which are delaying their
rollouts in various ways we started
about 35 minutes ago so at this point
I'm going to hang up and call it a day
if I were signing up for myself this is
where my patients would be exhausted